[Music]
when we look at political orientation
it tends to fall on a natural curve
so that indicates to us there may be
some processes of
natural selection at work there um can
you explain what you mean
when you say it falls on natural curves
so
when you get people to identify you know
their their political orientations on
various scales how much
how how far to the left how far to the
right when you ask them specific
questions about
values that are typically associated
with political conservatism versus
values that are typically associated
with political liberalism they tend to
follow the natural curve right so the
bell curve
there are some people on the extreme
right end who hold really strong
conservative beliefs most of us fall
somewhere in the middle and on the left
and on the left the same thing there's
there's kind of a
there's kind of a wing on that side as
well
um so that tells us that there are some
natural processes that work there
so you know the the great thing about
evolutionary sciences i think is that
they can explain
complex confusing human behaviors
with such parsimony such such um
explanatory power and i think i think
you know
political behavior is one of those
because we all know how
how emotionally charged political
behavior can be and how confusing it can
be
right and usually when something carries
a lot of emotion
along with it it tells us that hey this
this may be related to survival and
reproduction this is old
this is old and it sometimes co-ops
rational thinking
so looking at looking at the underlying
psychology i think is critically
important for understanding our
political selves
so one of the biggest predictors of
of political orientation is
xenophobia versus xenophilia so
xenophobia is
the extent you know having a suspicion
of outside people
and it doesn't have to be an outside
race it could be an outside political
orientation it could be an outside
gender sexual orientation it could be an
outside race
and on the opposite end of the spectrum
is xenophilia how much you are drawn to
new
cultures drawn to people from the
outside more likely to speak a foreign
language or travel to india or wherever
if you're not from india so
when we use those kinds of scales to
predict political orientation
it maps on with a great deal of
precision so those on the extreme right
well it's probably fair to say those
who endorse higher xenophobia
tend to be more politically conservative
and the inverse for those who are
highly xenophilic so and i think it's
important to voice it that way because
we had fears of outsiders eons before we
had anything resembling modern day
politics right
so those with kind of uh an ingrained
propensity to
to fear outsiders are more likely to be
more politically conservative
um and also fear of germs
when we look at fear of germs it tends
to map on in the same way those who are
more politically conservative tend to
fear germs more often
so one of the things that i find
interesting one of the theories that i
find interesting is that
these fears may have benefited us in our
evolutionary past and falling on the
natural curve
may have benefited us in our
evolutionary past
in the days of our ancestors we had
nothing like
antibiotics hand
you know hand wash vaccines
so people people whole populations could
get wiped out
by something very simple like the common
cold and certainly the flu
well who were the biggest vectors of
disease in our evolutionary past
outsiders were right outsiders bringing
in
pathogens that we didn't have an
immunity for
so so you know it may have benefited our
evolutionary past to
be wary of outsiders right to not to to
to not allow outsiders into your camp to
be suspicious of outside people because
of that
right so um but on the other hand
you know we might we have populated the
whole earth and
and migrating to new lands has its
benefits as well interfacing with new
people has its benefits as well
you know if you're too insular there are
problems like genetic bottlenecks you
may exhaust the resources in your in
your
in your territory whereas on the other
end
if you're more open to outside people it
allows you greater genetic diversity
it allows you to acquire technologies
and and resources that you might not
be able to acquire if you just wanted to
stay put with your with your own kind
so you know when we look at kind of the
core values of
of of people on the left or right
we can see those dynamics at play you
know people on the left tend to be more
open to other cultures
they tend to embrace other cultures they
tend to be more
sexually open because you know
that would be helpful to you if you're
if you're migrating to a new tribe of
people
and would allow you to interface with
them interbreed with them it would allow
you to acquire certain kinds of
immunities
that they had to local pathogens by
interfacing
and and having offering with them uh but
there's a certain advantage to staying
put
so these are some very core um
underlying psychologies behind our
political orientations
and they may have served an old purpose
you